hey man what's going on how are you good
man how about your show
i'm doing all right are you are you
doing any time basking
in the glow of being named top country
artist
at the billboard awards how does that
make you feel man
i don't know there wasn't much time for
basking i had to i had to put
you know a deluxe album out the next
week so
it was more like basking in the in the
lights of
interviews and stuff
just getting on with it right yeah like
state music
you're nominated for uh for five awards
here at the cmas you know what would
what would the luke that used to fold
clothes for a living
say if you knew that he was having this
kind of run
man he'd be pretty pumped i'll tell you
um and i i mean i am too you know i mean
same guy really you know um
i'm excited and you know can't believe
it all at the same time and
i'm just you know i'm just trying to
enjoy it as much as i can these days you
know it's
um i have a chance now i think more than
ever
to sit back and and kind of take a
breath a little bit
just because of you know the way the
world is at
at the moment so um you know obviously i
wish that things were different but um
but i'm also thankful for that at the
same time yeah you've had a few crazy
years of just
i mean i imagine just non-stop working
and i'm sure
obviously having a good time doing it as
well looks like you're having a great
time doing it
you know when you think back to when you
started performing live
what was a big crowd to you back then
um i mean probably like a hundred people
would have been like a big
like would have been real big yeah and
now
you can pack stadiums now you could do
thousands of people yeah yeah man it's
crazy you know to think about how
quickly
it's happened it's been i mean i guess
it's been nine years since i started
playing guitar
so and really from the inception of it
to now has been insane
what do you think it is about the music
you make that people really connect to
i don't know i think it's just like it's
just me man you know i'm not any
different
than i was when i started and um i think
people can tell
that i have a good time doing what i'm
doing when i'm up there and
i think that goes a long way do you have
any
uh any superstitions when it comes to
you know getting out on stage or even
you know preparing for awards shows
no i don't really you know um i you know
i don't write
any uh you know acceptance speeches or
anything like that beforehand
um i try to i try to go up there and and
just say
what i want to say and what i'm feeling
in that moment and
as far as stage goes i mean the only
thing that i really need is a
is a mixed drink that's about as
superstitious as i get
yeah you know you were
you talking a little bit about how
things are were so different this year
imagine if this was happening for you
the kind of award recognition that
you're getting this year in a more
crowded year you might not have had the
time to
say celebrate with your wife
celebrate with nicole in sort of a
wind-down manner
how is she taking to all this man i mean
you know we've been we've been living
together for a couple years and she's
been there since
i mean we you know we were essentially
dating before
you know i had anything going on i mean
so
she's been there kind of from the start
of when i moved to nashville a little
bit to
to now and so it's been it's been crazy
i mean she
you know she takes it about as well as
somebody can i would imagine
um and so you know she's real supportive
and she's always there for me and stuff
and
you know which i'm very thankful for um
but she's fantastic and she's been
fantastic through this whole thing
yeah the music video for loving on you
is a great one it kind of
kind of shows the idea that you guys go
back like that you go way way way back
on your wedding day who shed the most
tears
oh me for sure
big time it was me yeah what was that
celebration like
for you guys it was fun man i mean it
was a lot different than
um you know what it was supposed to be
um but i think it ended up in in my eyes
being really perfect
in a lot of ways you know we had a
really small group
of people that were really really close
to um we got to hang out with everybody
and enjoy everybody's company and so it
was it was pretty perfect man
what was it like to be able to have her
on set for uh
for loving on you at the end there the
little tag on the end is really cute
what was it like to be able to actually
do that together well that was good i
mean we recorded it
you know during this so i think it was a
little different than a normal
video day um because everybody was you
know kind of
you know wearing masks and and you know
had to stay
a certain distance from each other and
um so it was you know that part of it
was was a lot different but it was fun i
think that was her
that wasn't her first time being in a
video either so she was a
little bit had a little a little bit
knew more what to expect this time
around
yeah what have you guys been doing in
order to um
i don't know i guess to keep your
spirits up to keep motivated
uh during this time man we just uh
we you know we've been hanging out at
the house we got we got uh
two cats a dog and and a bunch of
chickens and
um so we you know just hang out outside
and try to watch some good shows where i
think we're re-watching the office for
like the
millionth time right now so that's a lot
of smiles
uh anytime you watch that and i just do
it as much as you can i've been writing
a lot of songs and
and staying busy and i think that's it
man just trying to focus on on
all the good stuff that you is is the
only way to get through it
yeah and you know like you said you're
focusing on uh the deluxe version of
what you see is what you get what are
what are fans getting with this deluxe
version
well they're getting some bunch of songs
i recorded uh this
this june uh kind of emits this pandemic
or whatever you want to call it and
um so you know just some stuff some
stuff i wrote during some stuff i wrote
before
um but went in and uh just wanted to
give them something new to listen to to
be honest i mean there's no ulterior
motive other than that um you know i
know as a fan and i love
having stuff you know frequently and
having uh hearing new stuff and
and so i wanted to be able to give that
uh to the fans as well
are you constantly writing are you
constantly creating music because it
seems like your output is
is i mean there's a lot of songs out
there that you're putting out back to
back to back
yeah man you know i write a lot i don't
think it's necessarily
uh more it's definitely not more than a
lot of folks i don't think but it's just
um i go and i kind of write in you know
blocks a little bit i'll go right
you know for two weeks with people and
um you know come out of that
with 14 songs but when you're writing a
song a day
i mean you really have time to make sure
that that song is as good as it can
possibly be
so i think that's important i think i'm
a quality over quantity guy when it
comes to that kind of
stuff so um i really just try to focus
on on making whatever song i'm
working on be as good as it can be yeah
are you uh
working on the follow up man i i don't
know necessarily i have a bunch of stuff
in the can
uh since i you know recorded this in
june and
um i don't think there's any necessarily
timeline on
uh me going back in and doing something
else but i've got plenty of stuff and
and when that time comes i'll i'll be
ready
yeah are you wearing the crocs right now
i'm not exploring i'm not wearing the
crocs this second
um i'm too afraid to get them all dirty
they're pretty good looking
uh when they're crispy out of the out of
the packaging so yeah they're super
clean
super clean how did that collaboration
come about
it came about a couple years ago and
i've just been kind of wearing them and
um it was just it felt like a fun thing
to do and and people seem to love it so
um
it's been a nice little creative outlet
for me
uh there's a bunch of other artists out
there that are obsessed with crocs post
malone being one of them
can you foresee a time when the two of
you might be able to cross paths and do
something musically
and or crocs related man i think
i think that would be really cool you
know i'm a big fan of his and
um you know i don't i don't really know
what he's up to
um these days i'm sure he's probably
working just like i am i know he was
at the billboard awards i think nobody
really saw each other at that event it
was like super
super locked down and stuff like that
but i've hung with him played some shows
with him in the past and hung out with
him on a couple occasions and he's a
great guy man so
we'll see who knows
you